no and welcome to this video Jimmy the
saint wise is raining so no as always
not hire I think just a second
but switch the microphone off a big
sneeze IAM okay it's playing the Scotch
four nights or no this fall nights so
and this often leads to a very close
positions where long complicated
maneuvers happen let's see what that's
going to be the main thing in this game
like to eat success what they do kind of
wonder if this is the right timing and
that 98 looks a bit funky in this
production to be honest let's ask him
about the bishop they are probably
pushing everyone anyway so yeah normally
black goes for us head up like this so I
am trying it can easily um I get to
position that look a little bit like the
news of India loopner variation however
it seems unlikely that white war push t5
in the near future maybe yeah maybe
people I'm called a five
hmmm curious what is this plenty with
this pawn and that we closed it down
okay surprising he wants to play a 4
here 94 and then F for my pieces pieces
are a little bit strangely placed I have
to play g5 but it's not maybe not such a
big deal
if five is a pretty substantial weakness
IAM night eh is seven it looks very
strange i know maybe there is some I
mean this is perfectly okay for me if I
have some time to sort this structure is
not that bad but i wonder if i get the
time he says I don't get the time wow so
he wants to push in the center here yeah
maybe this is the way to punish my
artificial set up so they have to take
her in so Bishop Jake's right so if i
take now what is he doing here is that
really working then it's going to be
five coming and I'm toast your auntie
threatens Bishop takes d5 with d6 next
okay
well and so if i take it five it's not
even possible to get some sort of player
some sort of position how can I put
myself of course looks completely
ridiculous I mean I was aware of the
potential problems but I didn't expect
this kind of Hammer hammer blow now you
can take you five yeah he is also far to
cook the end or Bishop d3 evening and I
lot not now but okay if he goes back and
I would like to play f6 night f 795 but
he's got Bishop d3 now you know he wants
to completely kill me yeah probably it
works
they can just take c4 right what a game
check yeah it's so bad it's very hard to
screw it up for him very very hard I'm
just down everything yeah yeah I just
play it this said I was far too
artificial it was played like there is
no time in chester and he exploited this
very nicely yeah it took him ages but
it's a good move
it's lost anyway I'm taking it was
extremely easy black resins play total
crap at the moment ready total crap
really really awful yeah so I think up
to here this is at least somewhat
playable yeah they need he shut it down
which gym I didn't really think this was
so dangerous and and also I don't don't
don't believe the computer here by the
way I don't don't do it all that seems
like a decent huebner to me at least
first glance but some things some things
don't don't dad out okay Ruby one okay
what I clearly have to replace as root
this year the zook maneuver I wanted to
play the rook there that Bishop CH to
cover be several and then kind of get
them to the King side but I have to have
to probably do what the engine suggests
suggests what I don't quite see yet this
movement is why this position is such a
big disadvantage the engine um I mean I
have analyzed this position types quite
a bit from the huebner variation and the
engine tends to value the space that
white has here quite high labored and
this is not often totally correct like
hear the engine gives white almost upon
advantage and i can tell you
they can believe me or not that this is
wrong this position isn't all that bad
for black for example in almost any
ending like it's very ok a 5c for
potential weaknesses and I mean you can
say ending and you get checkmated but
how how exactly is black going to be be
killed quickly that that's just not
going to happen and the bishop won't see
one can be a prettier can be a problem
peace in the long run and I don't think
what is better like that 0.8 is wrong
simply so what what do I do here this
position Jay I'm probably just queen d 7
or something like that Queen f6 I just
have to reorganize a pistol but if i can
get this look like c8c 7 and back and I
mean there is no tactical anything going
on I don't want to take yeah I think
this is this is not bad what the engine
is giving then it wants to take and play
Queen d3 yes but white is just not
better hear this position it's just not
true kind of kind of curious what what
what the engines evaluation is all about
him now there's simply nothing that you
can attack here so Oh what it that gets
kind of funny am I not just okay I
cannot play night of 60 right d 60 okay
maybe I shouldn't shouldn't allow the
Queen train okay I don't want to analyze
is now until till the end of the day but
i don't think that black is worse like
this maybe maybe slightly but not 0.8
yeah but this is definitely wrong and
yeah after this f4 was a real real
killer yeah but the position is already
very bad yes F for coming and I mean g5
was not a happy move but I felt they
have to do it to prevent a forward and
implemented the engine plays Bishop a
four year which is how kind of difficult
to comprehend and know this well okay
that's a ridiculous position for black
yeah boy this is of course very nice you
just killed me completely oops yeah a
pretty terrible game what kind of same I
really have to get back in shape I don't
know below 2300 is really bad so
exceptionally bad played thanks for
watching though